petit enfant dé paris la grenouille à
bout portant
même la nuit caché sous les feuilles de
nénuphars il leur est impossible d'en
réchapper avec l'arbalète anti
grenouille de quatre mètres de long
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui les poules et des canards
n'ont rien à craindre mademoiselle
stocks va préparer un plat peu commun
une blanquette de grenouilles mais c'est
un plat gaz course
sinon ce n'est pas gascon mais nous
l'avons adopté ça se fait un petit peu
partout vous savez mais maintenant nous
avons pas mal de nos yeux dans les
fossés d'aritz note dans les mains des
lots sous serre alors les jeunes soit
100 milliards le plan ii des grenouilles
et on fait souvent la tête de grenouille
pour la préparer il faut farine et les
grenouilles
on les fait rigoler dans de la graisse
de canard une fois dorée on les retire
dans ce jus il faut jeter un hachis de
nyon ont fait un roux avec une cuillère
et de farine et du bouillon de poule on
jette les grenouilles dans ce bouillon
et on laisse réduire à petit feu pendant
20 minutes et 8
je fais une liaison avec 2 jaunes
d'oeufs
je mets un peu deviner 2 de v je remue
bien
j'ajoute un peu de sauce chaude de tôle
et j'aurais pas celui où nous il mais
c'est terminé et à ça c'est fini
d'asseoir c'est terminé peut-être celui
ci me lasser revanche pu goûter à bien
s'il revient sur vous et goûter un oui
oui c'est délicieux mais alors c'est pas
un plat gascon qu'est ce qu'est gascon
alors et bien ce qu'est gascon c'est la
poule au pot et puis le farsi à la poêle
vous ne connaissez pas le faire si la
part du tuning mais je vais le faire
tout de suite
alors je fais un machine avec du jambon
de bayonne du foie de volaille ou du
persil un hachis d'oignons l'a fait en
une pointe d'ail haché bien que ce soit
ses seins et une poussette
ce sera chez une fois que ce sera chez
je vais ajouter de la mie de pain et
deux trois pourquoi un peu de sucre en
poudre et bien pour l'adoucir l'oignon à
ce que l'oignon est un sacré alors le
sucre en poudre a eu aussi un peu
l'oignon mais tp est un tour de moulin
de poivre du sel et un ménage tout ça en
fait un bon mélange entre mélangez 1
tapez pressé j'ajoute un peu demi de
pain pour lier le mât farce ce que ça tu
as épaisse pour la phase se tiennent
bien dans la poêle clou le bien à ce
qu'il faut colossal s'ils sortent bien
roulé pour tous ne se désagrégera dans
le dans la société il faut le roulé
petit à petit doucement sur un feu très
doux et avec deux fourchettes
il n'aura mère mettez ça dans la troupe
de fait principalement et quelquefois
aussi dans la coupe du dimanche on a les
yeux on a les oignons et le
manche quand une volaille est un boulet
et on a le poids et le gésier qui sait
la face alors cette économie et pour mac
est facile bien haut la tête tu es tu
bien en quoi est elle aux open avec
square ou thalasso pour la voilà jeu
même en facile dans la soupe
là et il va puis la petit feu pendant
une demi-heure et tout à l'heure nous
mangerons la face avec du salé de porc
que j'ai mis un petit peu dans la
marmite
après l'assaut
[Musique]